so you have thoughts on Valentine's Day
here well yes Valentine's Day it's
coming up very soon
yes and I feel like every year guys
screw it up looking at you
not the park guy not the park guy so I
have some ideas for guys that are
watching the show that wants some advice
so I'm gonna who where am I looking
oh my god oh I'm gonna look into here
the guy up there I'm looking at you if
you're buying
[Applause]
no I warned you no one warned you all
the sudden my band did this really want
to be a part you know they just start
playing we were playing music under your
PSA oh geez okay all right oh I'm
sweating I'm sweating guys you ready go
T in the back you ready all right if
you're buying late is a gift for
Valentine's Day get a gift card I know
it's impersonal get a gift card I
promise you I promise you I promise you
it will be less of a fight than buying
something in the wrong size if you are
buying something for your girlfriend of
two or more years and decide to buy her
jewelry that's not an engagement ring I
suggest you give her that jewelry box
wearing a helmet because you're about to
get bad speech I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this